one thing we don't talk enough about
in the discussions of motherhood and stay at home mom
motherhood is the economics of happiness
now I know we always have to say that money doesn't buy you happiness
but what can buy you is an easier life
and when it comes to being a stay at home mom
that is such an crucial conversation
because I have been a stay at home mom for 10 years
we are not in the same financial situation as we were when I started
and that has made a humongous difference
now we were never really struggling financially
but we were definitely not in the same place that we are now
so when I talk about being happy being a stay home mom
about job satisfaction in the role
right um
these are things that you need to take into consideration
especially when you're consuming motherhood content online
comparing your life to theirs
because I would say there's three things that greatly
greatly affect your happiness as a stay at home parent
1 your partner
how involved in participatory your partner is will make or break your experience
number two I would say is finances
your ability to outsource any of the duties that are under your umbrella
will greatly change your perspective on being a stay home mom
you know
anyone can be hashtag blessed when they can take a date night when they need it
or hire a cleaner to help out and third
and somewhat related I would say
is your mental and physical health
cause even if you were married to the most amazing partner in the world
and you have the funds to be able to outsource
any sort of domestic labour you want
if you are struggling mentally
you will be living in a prison of your own mind
and that is a complete crap shoot and affects people of both high and low income
however
those with expendable income will have better access to mental health services
and people to watch your children for you to get a break
so still still a factor everyone experiencing motherhood
is experiencing motherhood in a completely different way
and these factors factor in
to how well they're gonna be coping with the stresses
both physical and mental of the role
so in order to be an informed consumer of social media
especially surrounding something dude
so deeply personal and intimate as a motherhood journey
please keep in mind those three factors
because they make or break someone's experience
no I don't mean that everybody with expendable income
is going to have a easy time in motherhood
and I'm not saying that everybody who is doing every single domestic job
and has no breaks isn't going to be possible to be having a great time either
I'm just saying when you're watching creators
and you're comparing yourselves to things you see online
to keep in mind that the economics of happiness plays a role
the village is important if you don't have it by birth or by community
having the funds to pay for it will make things easier
because the village has always been necessary in child rearing